oh man I I can't believe this is where
we are but Donald Trump has been caught
on a recording during a private event
yesterday implying that the Ukraine
whistleblower should be killed should be
executed it's not just the media that
Donald Trump has no respect for it's
also whistleblowers it's really anyone
who doesn't pray at the altar of Trump
and this apparently includes killing
people Donald Trump spoke yesterday to a
group of US diplomatic staff in New York
City and it was recorded the LA Times
got their hands on the recording and
Trump implies that whistleblowers should
be killed like we used to do with
treasonous people take a listen to this
basically never saw never saw the call
many members of the court heard
something and decided that he or she
over the holiday so like promises fine I
want to know who's the first of the game
the whistleblower was the person who
became the missile blower the
information because that's opposed to a
spy you know what we used to do in the
old days when we were smart the spies
and treason
you know what we used to do in the old
days - people - who make who commit
treason Donald Trump is talking about
killing whistleblowers and then people
in the room laughs and you know I don't
know if those are nervous laughs or
laughs of agreement but the president is
effectively saying here I wish I could
have Americans who are inconvenient to
me politically executed and there are
reports of this recording summarizing it
as Trump slams the whistleblower it's
not that Trump is slamming the
whistleblower Donald Trump is suggesting
that the whistleblower should be
executed and that is obviously much much
worse and it's not a surprise look at
which relationships have failed under
Donald Trump and which brutal dictators
he is absolutely enamored with France
Canada Germany the UK our relationships
with those countries those Western
diplomatic Democratic historical allies
our relationships with them are worse
than they've been in a very very long
time under Donald Trump and then on the
other hand Donald Trump is just smitten
with Putin and Duterte and Kim jong-un
and r1 and you know I can't even
remember the full list offhand we've
since found out over the last day or so
that the whistleblower by the way the
first whistleblower there's now news of
another whistleblower and IRS
whistleblower and we'll talk about that
on Monday we've now found out that the
Ukraine whistleblower is believed to be
a CIA officer who was working at the
White House and as you can imagine the
whistleblower would be at immediate risk
if information about them were published
now before we even knew that this was a
CIA officer I said if the whistleblowers
identity becomes public I would be
extremely scared to be anywhere in
public that trumpets might be because
that person's life is immediately at
risk but even beyond that now we know or
it's being reported by the New York
Times that this is a CIA officer their
identity needs to be protected hopefully
it will be the CIA is saying that
protecting
the identity of the whistleblower is
there a quote highest priority and I
hope that that's the case I would not be
surprised I hate to even dabble in this
but if by Monday we find out that Donald
Trump has tweeted the name or some other
information about the whistleblower if
it becomes known to him it would be
disgusting it would be deplorable it
would be one of the worst things that I
can imagine but it would not be
altogether surprising and we will follow
up on this on Monday we will tell you
about the second whistleblower on Monday
and there's so much more going on